hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast green cards for
scientific researchers how to win your
EB 1a and iw case presented by Brian
Gibson a USA immigration lawyer at gets
Ihnen shots I'm Suzy Valdez of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth and sponsored by get sent in
shots before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time during the presentation just
click on a green Q&A box located at the
lower left of your presentation window
type those questions into the box that
appear on the screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also notice
that you're viewing the presentation in
a slide window to enlarge that window
just click on the screen icon and
located at the lower right if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support button
or click on that Q&A button and let us
know you're having a problem good news
this presentation is educational and
offers continuing education credits
click on the button in the bottom left
hand corner to follow the process for
obtaining your credits please join me
now in welcoming our speaker brian gets
in brian is a graduate of University of
Pennsylvania law school with 20 years of
experience he is a leading u.s.
immigration lawyer who represents
scientific researchers in applying for
green cards and he's the principal of a
Bowtique immigrant Gration law firm
based in Philadelphia Brian has given
presentations on green cards for
scientific researchers at numerous major
scientific conferences the Wistar
Institute and at universities he often
provides a money-back guarantee to
qualified applicants giving clients
confidence that they will get results
for more information go to his website
at researchers green card com
I will now turn the presentation over to
our presenter welcome Brian
hi everybody thank you so much for
having me today leopards and I'm going
to talk about immigration for scientific
researchers so again
Susie gave a little background about
myself I'm a graduate of University of
Pennsylvania Law School and I have been
representing scientific researchers I'm
going into my 22nd year and I've
authored a book on how to obtain a US
visa based on achievement and you know
over the years I've handled hundreds
upon hundreds of cases so in the year
2017 the place to start when talking
about immigration is with President
Trump and his main focus is on illegal
immigrants and building a wall so again
that's what his policy agenda is about
it's to deport criminal aliens and
secure the border and scientific
researchers are you know still welcome
in the year 2017 to apply for green
cards in the United States so nothing
has really changed when it comes to
applying for a green card based on your
research accomplishments and you know
there's a lot of rumors out there in
terms of what is happening what might
happen and there are all rumors pretty
much so you know the system is still the
same and they are still approving cases
for scientific research to get green
cards in the United States so everyone
should feel confident about moving
forward with their case if you want to
get a green card and to live and work
permanently in the US so most of you who
are listening to this right now you're
here in the United States in one of
three categories you're either here as
an f-1 student j1 postdoc or you are
working on an h-1b visa so these are the
three most common types of non immigrant
visas that you would have before you
would get the green card and when you're
thinking about the green card you really
want to think about the big picture and
the roadmap that you are going to take
in order to eventually have permanent
resident status and you need to think
about maintaining your underlying
non-immigrant status and when is the
best time to go ahead and apply for the
green card and you always want to have a
plan B in case plan a doesn't work so
again keep in mind where you want to go
and everybody's case is different so
somebody you know might be looking to
apply earlier because of a spouse or
because they want they're working in
academia and they want a green card to
go to industry or they need funding and
then in other situations it might be
better for somebody to wait a little bit
longer to let their level of citation
grow or for whatever reason so when we
look about the timing of when to apply
out of a non-immigrant status again
everybody has their own unique situation
so for those who are in F status after
you graduate usually from your PhD
you're going to have optional practical
training work authorization and this is
three years total you get 12 months
initially and then you get a 24 month
stem extension so during this three-year
period you can work to build your
credentials towards a green card filing
and perhaps you would even file for the
green card while you're still in this
opt period so again the normal course is
f1 visa to opt to h-1b status from a
non-immigrant perspective and h-1b is a
dual intent visa whereas an f1 is a
non-immigrant intent visa so what that
means is that if you
needed to apply for an i-485 green card
application you could still hold your
h-1b status and get an h-1b visa while
that was going on whereas if you have
applied for a green card out of student
status you could not extend that step so
when it comes to h-1b for the private
sector there's something called the Visa
Lottery and that is every April and
there's a lottery and there are 85,000
total visas available there are
sixty-five thousand regular visas and
twenty thousand for those with us
master's degrees and then if you're
going to do a university postdoc job
you're a cap exempt from h-1b meaning
you could go directly into h-1b so if
you're graduating and you're a student
and you get your opt work authorization
then the planning of your green card
might be different if you're going to go
to a university or if you're going to go
to the private sector because if you go
to the private sector you might need to
apply for the green card out of your
student status because if you don't get
an h-1b cap number then you would either
need to have the green card or you would
have to go back to a university to have
an h-1b or a J if you know that you're
going to go to a university after your
opt and that they are going to sponsor
you for h-1b then you have a little bit
more flexibility in terms of maybe
taking some more time to build your
credentials towards a green card filing
and the h-1b you can hold that for six
years so if you're a graduating student
you can have three years of opt and six
years of h-1b and that's nine years
before you would need a green card so
the odds of winning the h-1b visa
lottery this past April there were
approximately a hundred and ninety nine
thousand applications for the 85,000
slots and that was down
from April of 2016 where there were
237,000 applications so again h-1b
status can be granted for three years
and can be extended for a second
three-year period for a total of six
years and h-1b status does not
automatically result in a green card or
permanent residence you have to be able
to still have a petition for a green
card separate from the h-1b so there's
two primary paths to a green card the
first is the most common for foreign
nationals seeking green cards through
employment and that is called a
permanent labor certification and that
you have to have an employer to sponsor
you and the employer has to do certain
recruitment in newspapers and online to
demonstrate a lack of US worker
availability for the job and the
employer has to pay for the perm labor
certification part of that process and
the second weight is trying to avoid
having to demonstrate a lack of US
worker availability and that would be
through the eb1 which is extraordinary
ability alien or outstanding professors
or researchers or eb2 which is the
national interest labor so everybody
listening right now should be thinking
about whether they can qualify for EB 1a
which is extraordinary ability b 1b
which is outstanding professors
researchers or eb 2 which is ni w in
order to avoid the labor certification
so again this would be based upon your
scientific research accomplishments you
would say you would ask the government
to not care about u.s. worker
availability based upon what you have
accomplished in your past so again I
talked a little bit at the beginning
about the timing of everything so you
have to be able to manage that you're
always maintaining a non-immigrant
status to bridge the gap to filing for
the Green
so in some cases you might need to
extend your h-1b status beyond six years
in order to be able to keep working and
that can be done one of two ways which
is if a perm case or even an i-140 EB
one a B or ni W is filed before the end
of your this year of h-1b in which case
you could extend your h-1b status beyond
six years in one year increments or if
you had an approved i-140 petition then
you could extend your h-1b status beyond
six years and three year increments if
necessary and this typically only comes
up for people from China or India that
are in the eb-2 category where there is
a long wait for a green card and the
rest of the world typically can have at
a minimum a work authorization based
upon a green card filing before the end
of the six years but there are some
cases where you don't have that work
permit from the green card in time and
you have to extend beyond the six year
limit and then another strategy possibly
to extend beyond six years is called an
o1 a visa and that is the non-immigrant
version of eb1 a so again the what's the
big picture
when's the ideal time for me to file and
how do I keep myself in working status
at all time so with the perm labor
certification again an employer has to
sponsor you and the petition has to be
advertised according to law and if
there's a US citizen or green card
holder who meets the minimum
qualifications then one did not get a
green card so what we're talking about
and focusing on is getting a green card
while avoiding this perm labor
certification so the first category that
we're talking about is eb1 a
extraordinary ability and as I alluded
to this category is generally only used
by people who
from China or India there are certain
exceptions to that for certain reasons
but for the most part if you're from
China India you're going to look to do
this eebee one egg and the reason is is
that with the e b2 ni w the wait to get
a green card from china is approximately
four and a half years and the wait to
get a green card from India is
approximately nine years where for the
rest of the world in eb2 there is no way
to get a green card so with EB 1a
there's no way to get a green card for
China India or the rest of the world so
that's why if you're from China or India
the first thing we're going to talk
about is whether you might qualify for
EB 1 a so again EB one a important for
China and India due to the backlogs and
then the national interest waiver is
going to generally be for all other
countries and the reason is that the
national interest waiver is an easier
legal standard to meet than eb 1 a eb 1a
is more difficult you have to show that
you're among the small percentage of
researchers at the very top of your
field in the world whereas for ni w you
essentially have to show that your
research is of substantial merit and
national importance and that it would be
beneficial on balance for the united
states to give you a green card so
there's two ways to win an EB one a case
so the first way is receipt of a major
internationally recognized awards such
as the Nobel Prize and my note in the
slide is good luck with this method and
in my 20-plus years of practicing
immigration law I have never had a Nobel
Prize winner I have never used this
method and I never expect to use this
method so we move on to method number
two which is for everybody else who
never won a Nobel Prize and that is
satisfying three of ten evidence
categories so there is a legal
regulation under the Code of Federal
Regulations
that sets forth ten evidence categories
and in order to qualify for eb1 a you
have to meet at least three of the
categories and then on top of that you
have to show by what's called a
preponderance of the evidence that you
are in fact among the small percentage
of researchers at the very top of the
field in the world and this is under a
case called Kazarian it's ka-zar ia n
and that talks about this method of
satisfying three of the follow of the
ten categories and then on top of that
showing by a preponderance of the
evidence that you are among the small
percentage at the top so when I file a
case I like to try and go in to eveyone
a with more than three categories if I
possibly can and there are times where
immigration says that the researcher has
met three categories but hasn't met that
second standard of the preponderance of
the evidence so I'm gonna walk through
the ten categories and when one would be
preparing a national interest waiver
case you would look to these ten
categories as a guide in terms of how to
prepare a national interest waiver case
there are no set evidence rules when it
comes to an ni W you can submit whatever
evidence you would like but you still
tend to follow along with the EB 1a
categories so the first eb1 a category
is not a category that is frequently
used it's receipt of a lesser recognized
award for excellence in the field so
this is not a student award it is not a
travel award
it is not a young person award it has to
be an award that is open to anybody in
the field at any career stage and it has
to be on a national or international
level so these awards are difficult to
obtain because they're you know that
they're on that high level so you know a
lot of people have missed
conceptions that a student award or a
young researcher award is helpful and
it's not and it's never a good idea to
file a case and try and highlight a
piece of evidence that doesn't count so
when I'm preparing cases I always stay
away from young person student travel
things like that but again if there's
possibly an award that you could apply
for it to build your case then you
should go ahead and apply so the worst
thing that happens is you don't get the
award so with everything I'm talking
about I always tell my clients it's free
to ask it's free to apply and there is
no room to be shy when it comes to an
immigration case you want to advocate
for yourself and try as many things as
you can to build your case and you know
you you want to be thinking up now in
terms of listening to me about what can
you do to make your case stronger for a
green card application the second
category is achievement based membership
and associations in the field and again
this is not a common category because
it's difficult there are certain
organizations where anybody could join
like I could join the American Chemical
Society if I was interested in chemistry
or the American Heart Association if I
was interested in that so those types of
memberships do not count you have to
have a membership where you have to have
achievement in order to get in and you
have to be voted in so you know there
these are higher level and they're
usually reserved for things that are
people that are further along in their
career but you never know you know you
have to research what memberships could
be available in your field and there is
no reason to not apply because you
actually might get the membership if you
go ahead and apply so the third category
is a category that we tend to use if
it's available and this is published
material written about
you and your work in journals are major
media platform so what this means is
other people who are writing about your
work so there's things such as on the
Internet Science Daily News rx other
types of sites if you would go to
Science Daily right now on the home page
there's going to be a lot of articles
and they're talking about you know
researchers that have accomplished
things and the other types of material
is sometimes my clients have where
there's a book chapter that's written
and it's talking about their work or
there's a review article that's talking
about their work more than just in
passing where it's really mentioning
them by name and that's the key to the
Immigration Service is how they look at
this
is it has to be about the foreign
national so if your name is mentioned in
the text of the article that is very
helpful if it's about your work and even
if it's just about your publication and
your publication is mentioned at the end
I will still look to use that although
it's not as strong and convincing as if
the article is actually written about
you so if you're at a university then
your university has a press office and
your university likes to get good press
and good things written about them so if
you have a publication that is important
in your field then go to the university
press office and ask them if they can do
a press release or ask them if there's
any journalists that might want to talk
to you about it you know journalists
always need something to write about so
you know I have had clients get material
published about them because they went
ahead and asked so again advocate for
yourself you know that this is the
category so if you have a good
publication try and get somebody to
write about it okay so the next category
number four is participation as a judge
of others in your
and this is something that is almost
always used as one of the three
categories and it's something that you
can completely control and it's doing
peer review so what this means is you
know doing peer review for journals but
it's in your own name and not the name
of your supervisor so you want to ask
journals to do peer review just email
the journal maybe if you go to a
conference and there's some journals who
are exhibiting then you can you know
reach out to the journals even you know
to ask if they're available to give you
some peer review and you want to do as
much peer review as possible five is
better than three ten is better than
five and if you're able to do peer
review on an editorial level that is
excellent as well so sometimes I have
people tell me that oh I was offered
peer review and I declined it don't
decline it it's really helpful for your
green card case and it's something that
you have complete control over do as
much peer review as possible okay so
next and this is a category where 100%
of people applying for eb1 a try and
meet this category and its original
contributions of major significance in
the field and this includes commercially
viable patents your work being used by
others and conference presentations and
when it comes to conference
presentations poster is good an oral
presentation is better and a keynote
address is best and you know just to
sort of talk a little bit more about
this so the main way to prove original
contributions of major significance is
through reference letters and you're
really looking to have three sets of
reference letters set number one is
independent reference letters and these
are people who
who may not know you personally who
haven't worked at the same University or
company where you have worked and who
are not co-authors on any of your
publications and this is the theory
behind that is that if you were going to
have the lawyer in the office next to me
write a letter about me what would you
expect that lawyer to say the lawyer is
going to say that I'm a great lawyer
they're not going to say I'm terrible so
that's the the same thing with you
people who work with you immigration
knows that they're going to say nice
things about you so they're looking for
people outside of your circle to write
the letters and of the five letters you
maybe want to get three in the u.s. two
outside the US or the other way around
and how do you find these people again
you ask think about who has cited your
papers who has reached out to you to ask
about your research whom you may have
met at a conference ask your supervisor
for some help in terms of finding the
authors and you know everybody winds up
finding independent authors and I like
for the independent authors to talk
about all of the scientific
contributions that you have made there
you know my theory behind that is that
if your research has really impacted the
field the authors are going to know
about all of it not just some of it
whereas if one author just writes about
one aspect of your research and another
author writes about another aspect of
your research then maybe immigration
could view that as well the authors
don't know about all of your research so
I like to have the independent authors
talk about all of your research findings
and you know when we represent clients
we write the letters for our clients and
the way that we have the process work is
our clients would outline their research
for us and then after we receive the
research outline we will ask questions
to get details about the research
because you know I can look at any of
your CVS
I could see scientific terms that I
don't understand and the immigration
officer is just a layperson they have no
scientific background and they're not
going to understand the science either
and that's where a lawyer really helps
in preparing these types of cases is the
lawyer can explain your science in very
simple easy-to-understand terms that the
immigration officer can say hey I
understand what this person has
researched and accomplished I understand
the practical significance of it and why
it's important and how it's going to
benefit the United States so after the
questions are answered then we would
draft the letters and normally you would
just send it to the author and you know
nine out of ten times the author will
just sign what it is that you have sent
them and every now and then the author
will make changes and most of the time
the changes that the author makes is
still okay sometimes the author adds
language that can be detrimental to your
case and in that case I usually tell my
clients find another author and usually
what I mean by detrimental is your would
be getting a green card based upon what
you have accomplished in the past so
immigration doesn't like to see what may
happen in the future so when I have
letters where somebody changes the
language to say this you know will
impact the field or it may possibly lead
to a drug or you know there's a chance
that this could do something that type
of language could be very harmful to you
and immigration can use that language
against you so you know that in letters
them really the number one thing is to
make sure that the letters are always
focused on your past accomplishments and
not being speculative about what may
happen in the future
additionally there is law that says any
research that you have made even if
you're a co-author or worked as part of
a team can be considered your own
research so when you're writing
a letter you can say that you found this
you discovered this even if you were the
third author on the paper and that's
important to know and again immigration
knows that the lawyers are writing the
letters they're really just looking that
there are people out there who are going
to sign their name signing off on the
importance of your research so that's
the first set of letters is the
independent letters the second set of
letters is from your supervisors so even
though they are your supervisors
immigration still wants to hear from
them about you know what you did under
their supervision and what you're
currently doing and those supervisor
letters only we'll talk about what you
did under the direction of the
supervisor and then the third set of
letters goes towards these sort of what
I call supplemental letters so if you
have a commercially viable patent maybe
you get a letter from somebody that's
using your pen if your work is being
used by others this is really important
for example if there's a government
agency like the USDA that's interested
in your research then you know go ahead
and get a letter from them if there is a
you know you were asked to give an oral
presentation at a conference get a
letter from the conference as to why
they asked you to do the presentation so
you know if you have a lower citation
level then the use of work letters are
very important and you know I was
talking about the USDA I've represented
a client last year where she was in
agriculture and she basically made soil
you know more nutritious and better to
grow crops and because of her type of
field she did not have a high level of
citations so in order to overcome that
we got a letter from the USDA that they
were interested in her research and NASA
had been interested in her research
because she was helping to grow
in space and there were some
agricultural companies that were using
her research and we explained to
immigration that her research was more
practically oriented and due to the
nature of her field she didn't have a
high level of citation so we you know
use these letters and the case was
approved because we showed sort of the
practical significance of her research
so you always want to be creative and be
thinking outside of the box in terms of
how you can best present your case to
immigration so the next category that
everybody uses is authorship of articles
in the field in major trade publications
or major media and you know those again
it doesn't matter whether your first
author or second author or third author
if it's a publication then it's good and
you know to me the number of
publications is more important than the
impact factor of the journal so I would
rather see 10 publications than one
publication in nature again quantity
tends to be better than quality
sometimes with these types of cases so
going back to the level of citation this
is probably the number one gauge for
what are my chances for approval the
higher your level of citation the higher
the chance of approval so if you have
more than a hundred citations then
you're you know you're in a good place
for an ni W that might not be enough for
eveyone a or e B 1 B you know
immigration can be very sticky on this
but you know this is something that you
cannot control what I you know like to
advise clients is you know think about
the timing if you're maybe six months
away from having another 75 to 100
citations and maybe you wait a little
bit until that comes if you have between
fifty and a hundred citations it's
certainly possible to get approved again
the the agriculturalists that I just
told you about have less be in that
amount between 50 and
and was approved for eb1 a likewise if
you have less than 50 citations it's
still possible to get a case to prove
but it becomes more difficult so if you
have a lower level of citation how are
you going to overcome that in terms of
presenting your evidence to convince
immigration that even though this is
your citation level you're still among
the small percentage at the very top of
the field in the world or you still are
worthy of a national interest or any
b-1b international recognition is
outstanding so again the three most
common categories or the core three so
to say are the peer review the original
scientific contributions of major
significance and the publication so
number seven doesn't apply to
researchers which is display of work at
exhibitions or showcases number eight is
a critical role and this is something
that we frequently do for researchers
it's a leading or critical role for
organizations that have a distinguished
reputation I often use this to try and
meet a fourth category immigration is
often very difficult with this so you
know we have to show what made your role
leading or critical if you were at a
university did you get them funding did
you are you training other researchers
there you know did you is there a patent
that is being benefiting the university
right now or likewise for a private
company so we'd have to show how your
role is leaving or critical but again if
you're going to look for a fourth
category you know most people are either
having media or publications written
about them or they're showing that
they're in a critical role and then the
other ways to go would be memberships or
Awards so critical role is something
that you know you always want to try and
ask and at least see if either a current
or past employer would be able to give
you such a letter high salary compared
to others in the field this is generally
not done for researchers but you know
the
always an exception to the rule it would
usually have to be if you're at a
private company of some kind and then
again what doesn't apply is commercial
success in the performing arts so those
are the 10 categories for eb1 a again
China and India you're looking for EB
one a or e B one B the rest of the world
you're probably looking to file in an ni
W but these categories are going to
apply to NI W so I had talked a little
bit earlier about the o1 non-immigrant
visa and unlike eb1 a where you can self
file and you can also sell file in NI W
and self filing has benefits because you
could change jobs and still keep your
green card in EB 1a or ni W whereas with
EB 1b if a university is sponsoring you
for outstanding professor or researcher
you could only change jobs after your
green card has been pending for more
than 180 days but you know I'm sure some
of you have heard that there's been a
change under the trumpet administration
that all employment-based green card
applicants are going to be interviewed
now and that is going to make receiving
the green card take longer it will not
change the time it takes for you to
receive a work permit or travel document
but it will make getting the green card
take a little bit longer so if you have
that eveyone a or ni W then you can
change your underlying non-immigrant
status whether that's with an H or no
and still be able to keep your green
card so back to the oh this is really
used in two situations for you guys and
the first would be if you're working for
a private company and you do not win the
h-1b lottery then you could look to get
an o1 non-immigrant visa and that would
be applicable even if you are not from
India or China you might
no one non-immigrant visa and the other
would be if you're at the end of your
six years of h-1b status but for
whatever reason you can't maintain work
authorization in any other way then you
could look at the o1 visa to be able to
maintain the non-immigrant work
authorization so again this is the same
three out of ten categories for eb1 a
but you need an employer sponsor so
again it's the receipt of the
international award or you're meeting
three of the evidence categories and
what's the difference between eb1 a or
o1 a eb1 a is for a green card
ona is for temporary residents and
employment and eb1 a is the higher
standard and the reason for that is that
second Kazarian step to show by a
preponderance of the evidence that
you're among the small percentage a at
the top of the field that does not apply
to Oh 1a so with ona if you meet the
three categories you get the visa okay
EB 1b is outstanding professors and
researchers and this is also in a b1
category it's a little bit easier than e
b1 a so if you are from India or China
and you have an employer to sponsor you
for EB 1b you I would recommend that you
strongly consider that because it is
easier to get the case approved under EB
1b and to get a green card under eb1 B
you have to show international
recognition as outstanding you have to
have a qualifying employment offer which
I'll talk about in a minute and you have
to have at least 3 years of teaching or
research experience in the field so the
typical employment offer is a tenured or
tenure-track teaching position or it's a
research position at a university
without a fixed term and that is not a
postdoctoral research fellow it has to
be a higher position than a postdoc like
a research associate or a research
assistant or you have to have a
permanent research position at a private
company
and to talk a little bit more I'm going
to go back a second in the slide so the
three years of teaching or research if
you can use that gained at the PhD level
as long as you had research consider to
be outstanding at the PhD level so in
most cases you can count three years as
research you did at the PhD level toward
that three years and in terms of a
qualifying employment offer for a
private company there has to be at least
three other full-time researchers at the
company in a department division or
Institute of the company where there are
outstanding accomplishments and you
cannot count as one of the three
researchers so now we move to eb-2
national interest waiver and the
standard for this is you have to have an
advanced degree which all of you would
and you have to demonstrate that your
employment is in the national interest
and as of December 2016 there is a new
legal standard for Ni W and it's called
matter of dinosaur and the Immigration
Service can grant a national interest
waiver there's a three part test number
one is that your proposed endeavor has
substantial merit and national
importance and generally that's going to
be anybody who's conducting scientific
research is going to have substantial
merit and national importance whether it
has to do with healthcare or the economy
or the environment and you know we will
explain to the Immigration Service and
the cover letter that we drift how the
research is of merit and importance and
we'll give some literature usually from
government agencies talking about why
what it is that you're researching is
important number two is that you're well
positioned to advance the proposed
endeavor and this is looking at you know
what have you accomplished in the past
and you know how is that setting you up
now to continue your research and what
did your plans for work you do not need
a job offer and you could apply for this
even if you're outside of the US and
that's the same for the eb1 a and the e
b1 B but it's certainly helpful if
you're already in the US and working in
a non-immigrant status and you would
just tell the Immigration Service that
you're simply going to continue working
in your current position conducting
research in your field and speaking of
your field how you define your field is
important so you know especially if
you're going to want to change jobs
before the green card or even after you
want to define your field broad enough
that number one it covers everything
you've ever done in the past and that it
would cover any possible future job that
you might have but you know you don't
want to define your field too broadly
you don't want to say for example you're
among the small percentage of
researchers at the top of the field of
chemistry I mean that's a really big
field and it's hard to show that so you
have complete control in terms of how
you define your field for the EB 1a or
the NI W with EB 1b the field is
unimportant it's just the academic field
of your degree so you want to try and
make yourself a big fish in a small pond
while still defining your field broad
enough so for example you would say you
know understanding you know the
molecular mechanisms of proteins related
to heart disease if that's what you're
working on and what you've always worked
on so that's defining your field in such
a way that you know it's going to cover
what you've done but it's not too big so
that's being well positioned to advance
the proposed endeavor which is your
field and number three is on balance it
would be beneficial to the u.s. to waive
the job offer requirement and labor
certification so this is just making an
argument to immigration that you know
when you look at all of your past
accomplishments that the u.s. is going
to benefit from having you here and you
should not worry about US worker
and again national importance is
benefiting the US but you know it
doesn't have to be completely national
in scope although in most cases it will
be and again it's benefiting the economy
education health care environment safety
everyone's research is going to have
some kind of benefit and you know this
new legal standard it eliminates terms
like track record of success and degree
of influence on the field at the hole
which was under the old standard but you
know again immigration still looking at
what have you accomplished and why is it
important okay
so premium processing is available for
eb1 a and eb1 B but not for ni W and in
the year 2017 immigration has been
deciding all of these cases faster so
they have been deciding anti W cases in
about three to six months along with EB
one a and E B one B it used to take more
than a year but if you wanted to premium
process your EB 1a or e b1 B you could
do so for an extra 1225 you know we tend
to hear and see that sometimes
immigration is more difficult with
premium processing so you have to
balance how quickly do you want to get
the case to prove versus you know the
possibility of maybe increasing your
odds of a request for evidence or notice
of intent to deny if you do premium
processing and again back to the timing
getting the green card involves two
steps
there's the i-140 petition which is the
e b1 a e b1 B the ni W and then there is
the i-45 green card application and in
most cases you know if for the whole eb1
category and for the e b2 ni w were not
from China or India you have a choice
whether you want to file the 485 at the
same time as the i-140 or if you want to
wait for the i1
according to be approved and then file
the 45 after and a lot depends on your
status are you in Jace 1 status are you
an f1 status in which case you would not
want to file the 45 simultaneously
unless you absolutely had to or are you
in h-1b status which is dual intent in
which case if everything got denied it
would not affect your underlying status
so again there's a lot of strategy
there's a lot of timing involved and
it's all done on a case-by-case basis so
post filing issues I talked a little bit
about this if you are filing an EB 1a or
an iw you can change jobs without
problems with as long as you're still in
your field with an e b1 B if the
application is pending for more than 180
days you can change to a same or similar
job and you would have to file what's
called form i-485 J as in Jack with the
Immigration Service so what's new is h4
work authorization and you know the new
ni W standard makes it a little bit
easier for entrepreneurs to apply for a
green card in that category but h4 work
authorization is really only going to be
for people from China or India who have
an approved ni W petition or a EB to
perm case and then their spouses could
work so while there is a long wait for
China and India and EB to if you don't
qualify for EB one the silver lining is
that your spouse can work and again
there's been some rumor about H for work
authorization going away but it's just
rumor and we're not expecting that to
happen so you know what we do as lawyers
is we provide a money-back guarantee for
most of our clients who are well
qualified and what that means is that if
you're I 140 petition is approved we
will refund the attorneys fee and you
know our standard attorneys fee for a
case is $5,000 total plus $100 per cost
and the i-140 filing fee is $700 and we
offer a payment plan to our
clients where we will have a payment of
2350 initially followed by four monthly
payments of 687 dollars and fifty cents
each and if the i-140 petition is denied
we will give you back the $5,000 and
then we employ a team of science writers
to help draft the recommendation letters
and because these science writers really
have a science background and can
understand how to explain your you know
scientific terminology in simple terms
for an officer to understand and then we
have been doing this a very long time so
for more information you can visit our
website at research your green card comm
and on that site there is a online
scheduler where you can schedule a free
consultation with me directly and I
would be able to speak with you about
your individual case and situation so
thank you very much for attending and
now I'm going to take some questions
from Susie's going to come back in and
moderate thank you so much Brian and
thank you for that informative
presentation so I'm credibly important
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on that green Q&A lower left
button in the presentation window type
in the question into the box and click
the Sun button will enter as many
questions as we have time for today so
let's look at our audience members today
we have a great engaging audience our
first question Brian is I have a je visa
with a two-year requirement what should
I apply for my waiver of the two-year
rule once you
apply for once you apply for a waiver of
the two-year requirement you can no
longer extend your j1 status so you need
to really coordinate with your employer
about whether they're going to be able
to put you into h-1b once your j1 status
is waived if they can't put you in h-1b
then you're going to need to be able to
time the i-45 green card application so
that you have a working permit by the
time your J status expires so you know
normally the ideal time to apply for a J
waiver is right after you have received
an extension of your ds-2019 and the
reason you would need a j1 waiver is
that you cannot get a green card or h-1b
status without the waiver so you know
again we're going to talk on a case by
case basis with everybody but the main
thing to keep in mind is that you can't
extend your ds-2019 once you have the
waiver so you need to time that
accordingly with your employer thanks so
much Brian here's another great question
from our audience members if I have a
patent in another country not a u.s.
patent will that help my case
so the answer to the question is yes a
patent will help your case and but it
really only helps your case if it's
being used utilized so if a foreign
patent is you know if there is if it's
being utilized by a company then you
would want to get a company to write a
letter talking about how they're
utilizing your pen
even if patents are not being utilized
there's still an important part of the
case and I will include them in the
section on original scientific
contributions of major significance but
you know the key to a patent whether
it's foreign or US is is anybody
utilizing it and can you get just a
short one to two-page letter talking
about how they're utilizing it and that
goes back to the importance of the
Supplemental letters and showing how
your work is being used what's the
practical importance if somehow it's
being utilized by somebody that shows
immigration that yes you really have
impacted and influenced the field thanks
Brian and I want to think again our
audience today you have some fantastic
questions coming in our next question
comes from an audience member out of the
country
can you file a b-1a and n IW cases at
the same time so the answer to the
question is yes you can file a B 1 a and
n IW at the same time and you know that
would be one has nothing to do with the
other in EB 1 a would be decided on its
own merits and the NI W would be decided
on its merits and there is often
strategy in doing this and usually if
you do this you're not going to premium
process the EB one it if you were going
to premium process the EB one a then you
know you'll just wait the 15 days to get
the decision and hopefully it gets to
prove him you don't need the
i w so this type of strategy is most
often used for somebody from China or
India where we're not fully confident in
the credentials for eb1 a so what you
would do is you would file them both at
the same time the eb1 a and the NI W and
that preserves the right to extend h-1b
status beyond six years as long as
you're filing this before the end of the
fifth year and then you would let them
both play out so hopefully the eb1 a
would get approved but if the eveyone a
was denied then at least you have the NI
W and hopefully that gets approved and
then you would get in that long line for
EB to your spouse can get work
authorization and you could extend your
H beyond six years so they're the answer
to the question is yes you can file
eveyone a and then RW at the same time
it's mostly a strategy for somebody from
China or India but it is a strategy that
we use thanks Brian and here's a related
question to the one you just answered is
it recommended it is a recommendation
from a world expert when filing the
green card through eb1
and and IW categories is that something
that would be needed
so the answer is that is it absolutely
100% needed no if you had only United
States experts you could still show for
eb1 a that you have received sustained
national or international acclaim for
eb1 be that you have international
recognition as outstanding or for n IW
that you know your work is of
substantial merit and national
importance but you know i just used the
word international a lot and for that
reason well it's not absolutely needed i
always highly recommend that clients get
letters from people outside of the
united states
it shows a broader you know impact of
your research worldwide if you have
people from outside the US and when
we're talking about this five
independent letters as i indicated
earlier it's usually good to have three
in the US and two outside or the other
way around so you know it would be
strongly strongly encouraged for you to
get letters from people outside the
united states because it shows that your
research is really having a global
impact and that makes your case stronger
and to see on that same track brian you
mentioned letters here's another related
question to making a stronger case an
audience member wants to know how can
one work on making his stronger case if
employed in the industry
you mentioned letters what else can
someone do so again we
talked about there are certain things
that you can control and there's others
that you can and what you can control
whether you're an industry or academia
is doing peer review and what you can
control is publishing although an
industry you know you might not be able
to publish what you can control is
trying to get people to talk about your
work what you can control is applying
for memberships and applying for awards
if available but you know if you're in
industry then you really want to think
about controlling the timing of when you
apply more so than if you're in academia
if you're in academia you're gonna
continue publishing you're going to
continue getting your paper cited etc
but if you take an industry job and you
stop publishing then you may want to
consider filing a little bit sooner than
you otherwise would because you don't
want your publications to look stale you
know you don't want to be filing in 2017
when your last publication was in 2013
because you went to industry and you
stopped publishing so you know when you
go to industry you really want to think
about you know when are you going to
file and additionally I talked about the
practical use of work so if you're in
industry you're hopefully going to have
more of an opportunity to get letters
from other companies that are
benefitting from your work like
customers of the company that you're
working on or things along those lines
and those types of letters become you
know very important you know when you're
working in an industry setting and
they're likewise equally important in an
academic setting so you know again do as
much as you can to build your
credentials towards a green card file
thank you sir and we have time for one
more question from our audience here's
our final question what is the success
rate of obtaining a green card through
industry versus academia so the success
rate depends on your credentials it
doesn't really matter whether you're in
academia or whether you are in industry
you look at each person's you know
history their publication records their
citation level who's using their work
their memberships their you know awards
whatever it may be so what I tell
everybody is take the career path that
you want to take and as long as you and
then let the immigration follow
sometimes you can't always do that you
might for example if you don't get the
h-1b lottery you might be forced to go
back to an academia job but you know do
what you want to do without worrying
about the chances for success because
the chances for success depend more on
your credentials than they do on the
type of job that you're taking and then
once you decide what you want to do then
you'll figure out when what's the best
time for me to apply what's the best
category for me to apply and you know
you just sort of everything falls into
place and then also have that plan B
where if things don't get approved they
don't go the way you hope that they're
going to go how are you going to move
forward from there and you know never
give up always keep fighting and you
know hopefully you wind up getting the
green card and then once you have the
green card your entire career path is
open to you
Brian thank you so much and thank you
for your informative presentation again
for helping those that need this
information I'd also like to thank lab
roots and I'd like to thank Jetson and
shots for making today's educational
webcast possible Thank You audience
members before we go I want her in line
everyone that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
January 2018 you'll receive an email
from lab roots what do you know when the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and thanks
for joining us hope to see you again
soon bye